il va falloir rencontrer tech manquant comme on
aime Justin Trudeau c'est très dur pour
nous sur un CR Brunton esta Bano Toronto CTC
kajak nice English FG NPD et le
rendez-vous provençale discount de
mierda said ya beaucoup de Canada
division and Gen Con shabby  qui est Oliver
Oliver Nuri OpenSSL ma clé sur lui l'
amplitude a dit que j'adore une communauté je
démocratie couple DuPont faire la fête faire
son compatriote Shona Solomon dire que nous mettons
ça commence à partir d'ici et ensuite ça ira par
ici prenons ça comme un sept
mètres c'est  d'accord donc c'est la taille d'
une turbine oui c'est la taille d'une
turbine combien de temps faut-il pour mettre le turban
sur la tête
oui cela prend environ 5 à 10 minutes
auparavant nous avons environ 300 couleurs et
ensuite nous augmentons ces couleurs à environ
450 actuellement, nous sommes le plus grand
objet en Amérique du Nord mélangeant la couleur ou le
choix,
donc oui, cela a un impact, disons que peu de
gens aiment ça et ils viennent toujours
comme si nous avions besoin de ce genre de couleur de turban,
sauf les emoji, cela a pratiqué Isola
Tet  a City Oviatt well 400 on magazine
screw buddhic secure Don établit une
conscription puget part de la
population avec allocation supplémentaire et
choc à de la virgen do Punjab Lao alors
consultez la volonté malade donc vous
allez voter pour Jack soigné voir oui
nous allons  nous le soutenons alors espérons
qu'il sera notre prochain premier ministre au
Canada, c'est également important si votre
communauté, car elle
comprend mieux votre culture et ces valeurs
comme nous n'étions pas autorisés à porter Cape
pendant les vols,
évidemment ces dirigeants aident à
communiquer le  même message au
niveau supérieur justin trudeau portant des
vêtements de moteur en inde ouais ça ressemble mieux
quand vous êtes premier ministre nous en tant que
votre communauté
et vous vous sentez également fier de cela donc vous
étiez fier de lui portant ouais ouais nos
robes indiennes et notre sikhisme  symboles
scandaleux pas de conscription successeur un
alun me souvenir géographiquement
controversé mais le nouveau Parlement aujourd'hui les
députés et le butin pourraient intéresser le
Jackman Singh c'est  très dur très très
dur très très dur je suis un libéral mais
ça ne me dérange pas de voter pour le NPD donc
je ne sais jamais je ne lui dis pas non à
chaque fois quand il était député j'ai voté
pour lui
éviter Sigmund la  cantidad de Partie
conservateur populaire connaît le Sing se
tonneau Kiev Adama extremel Kronos à la
communauté mais à partir d'un incendie une
personne n'a pas rencontré le chanteur pour moi comme si
j'étais un Rodney gazeux je porte un sarong
nous rencontrerons chanter les membres de la famille  et l'
autre à faire
[Musique]